let's dive straight in so uh one of the
key topics that we wanted to kick off
with is the fact that kubernetes has
become the de facto standard for
building modern Cloud native
applications that are out of the box you
know scalable and are resilient to
failure right so kubernetes has seen
massive adoption over the course of the
last few years and has become the de
facto standard for uh building modern
Cloud native applications
an interesting Trend that we're also
seeing is the fact that kubernetes is
almost kind of being likened to what you
know Linux was
um you know many many years ago which is
just the abstraction layer for your
underlying infrastructure so kubernetes
is being positioned as almost a cloud
operating system that allows you to
build applications uh in a very
decorative way and allow you to deploy
those applications
um you know wherever whether it's
on-prem in your data center or in you
know public cloud provider
should we talk shafik a little bit about
why why kubernetes is the one why it's
it's as you I like your reference here
why it is the way as they would say in
the Mandalorian yeah what made what made
kubernetes win
yeah let's uh we could definitely talk a
little bit about that that do you want
to lead that off and you know I can
chime in yeah well I think I think you
hit on some of it I think that it was
built to mimic some of the patterns that
that we saw at the hyperscalers uh that
allowed them to build very scalable and
very resilient applications you know
they they realize that their lifeblood
they're very business dependent on that
site that app always being up and so
they had to come up with ways that uh
were were very resilient that that
prevented human error that prevented
hardware error from from taking down the
site and so this move the containers
really started there as they realized
that if we if we say hey forget the
server no one ever deploys anything to a
server we're using containers those
containers can be scaled effectively
they could be up and kubernetes really
takes those patterns and makes them
accessible to everybody so I think
that's one of the big reasons you want
to hit on another one or two
yeah absolutely right so the way
um you know the deployment patterns for
applications you know what kubernetes
enables you to do is um I use the term
declarative you know a minute ago right
so what I mean by that is you really
don't need to have any human
Intervention when you're you know
deploying your application so you simply
Define the resources that your
application needs
um resiliency is factored in through
maybe the use of like replicas where
you're able to deploy applications in a
highly uh available fashion and it's up
to kubernetes as the orchestration
platform to ensure that your application
stays online right so there really isn't
any room for you know human error or you
know there really isn't any intervention
needed as far as you know your
application is concerned right or
maintenance of your application is
concerned and then past deployment when
it comes down to operations and when it
comes something like maintaining your
applications it's much more simpler to
lifecycle manage you know applications
leveraging you know kubernetes apis you
know through automation right uh there
are capabilities that exist within
kubernetes that allow you to
um you know deploy applications using
um let's say a rolling strategy which
really ensure that you're able to
gracefully update versions of your
applications without having to go
through traditionally being an ID for
many years it's like you know it's not
your traditional maintenance Windows you
need to be worried about right that
we've had stories you know you know
people adopting kubernetes in production
and making changes uh you know
significantly without having to like
really factor in maintenance windows or
you know one of the value propositions
we talked to uh customers about our
operators about is the fact that uh you
really are not going to be spending you
know the same amount of time on
maintenance Windows as far as you know
application rollouts and deployments are
concerned right it really challenges
your developers to think about you know
application deployment or modern
software development life cycle in a
different way right and you're really
getting all the goodness of
um you know just like you mentioned the
hyperscaler culture it's something that
could be adopted within your own
Enterprise
and I want to hit on one other thing
before we get on the next slide and that
is that so we talked about why people
adopt the technology and of course it is
portable because you can run kubernetes
anywhere you're usually move to the
cloud you can run it on premises you can
run it on any Cloud but I want to point
out one thing which is really
encapsulated in both of those those
bottom bullets which is the innovation
in app deployment The Innovation
operations the innovation in in
developer experience is all around
kubernetes today if you were to choose
another platform then you would be
missing out on that Innovation and even
if you look at what the major I don't
know networking vendors look what what
uh say F5 Cisco is doing what what Palo
Alto networks is doing they are all
innovating on top of kubernetes now and
so if you want to be able to take
advantage of what's happening in
technology you have to be in this space
yeah kubernetes is the way I think I
think I think we can agree no completely
right and it just the ecosystem is just
so rich and there's just you know
vibrant from the perspective of all the
Innovation that's going on in there
right and uh you hit on networking
um just think of any other capability
that you would use to like you know
build out a platform right whether it's
um something that's you know security
related or you're talking about
integration with your existing uh
storage Fabrics or integration with uh
your existing you know Network Solutions
that allow for you know um you know
layer 7 capabilities right all of these
isvs were like working in this ecosystem
and unlocking all of these capabilities
for customers are definitely ensuring
that they do have a solution for
kubernetes and kubernetes is almost
becoming that substrate to like you know
build you know your platform on and you
know deploy your applications on just
purely because there's just a lot of
community and engagement and a lot of
where the Innovation is happening right
so if I'm a CIO and I'm attending this
webinar and I say okay great like Shafiq
can convince me we're going to uh
kubernetes we're done should they sign
off now
uh yeah yeah or should you get to the
next slide
okay all right so yeah that's uh that's
a great that's a great lead and right
and thanks for that then like um uh I
was I was joking when I said yes all
right so uh kubernetes by itself Again
kubernetes by itself is just giving you
the container orchestration capability
right so we're seeing a lot of um uh
adoption of a mindset of building teams
that are you know engineering platforms
right so what constitutes a platform
um you know coming going back to my you
know solution architect days and
Consulting days it's it's always about
like you know building something that
makes sense to the business that's going
to accelerate uh business outcomes for
you know a specific organization and
almost just kind of being very laser
focused about adopting Innovation to
really move the needle when it comes
down to solving challenges for your uh
organization right so that being said if
I'm I'm looking to build a platform and
I'm looking specifically to build a
kubernetes-based platform kubernetes
just gives me this one capability which
is what we just talked about or
discussed in the previous slide which is
robust in a container orchestration a
resilient way to deploy your
applications in order to build a feature
complete platform that allows you to
really meet those requirements that you
know your business might have you need
to like start figuring out what some of
the other capabilities you're going to
also build alongside kubernetes right so
it could be something along the lines of
uh figuring out how you integrate with
storage how you do Secrets management
what your application deployment
um you know formats are going to look
like how do I you know provide my
developers you know a service mesh
technology how do I handle uh networking
whether it's load balancing or trying to
like you know figure out how I'm going
to secure uh applications uh using you
know certificates or trying to like
ensure that all of the applications that
I deploy have um you know https you know
encryption for their mode of
communication or if my platform is going
to be serving or providing resources to
multiple teams do I have robust you know
multi-dependency included right so it's
not just about kubernetes it's much more
complicated than that because you really
need to like figure out how I'm going to
unlock all of those additional
capabilities and those were just some
examples and they're by no means a
complete list but the idea is you really
need to look at what's out there in the
ecosystem and which vendors you're going
to work with whether it's you know a
commercial vendor or uh the graphic out
here is the CNC of landscape right which
projects you're actually going to like
you know cherry pick and choose because
you have multiple options for each of
these capabilities I call them like
technologies that underpin a capability
right so the concept here is you need to
do a lot more work in building out that
feature complete platform or
quote-unquote batteries included
platform when it comes down to
communities yeah I think that I think
that's really important to to note
because you as you said kubernetes is a
container orchestration platform right
that's what it does and the reason the
the cloud native landscape is so complex
is that there are many things you need
for security for all of those things you
notice on top of it so if again like let
me put myself in the shoes or that that
csio I'm saying Okay so I I have to
settle on kubernetes and yes I do need
to secure everything I might need to
figure out do I need mtls so what do I
need do I need uh smart you know L7 load
balancing um what am I going to do about
Secrets does that mean that uh well it
seems like the decision to adopt
kubernetes was an easy one but there's a
lot more research in front of me because
I'm going to have to learn what each of
these icons means what's behind this
project what you what purpose is it is
it filling uh how does that fit with my
requirements and then choose each one is
that what you're telling me I've got
another six or nine months of work ahead
of me to try and figure out how to turn
this container orchestration platform
into a real you know Enterprise ready
Cloud native smart Cloud platform is
that right yeah it's going to cost me an
extra nine months yeah that's that's
exactly what it looks like right that's
typically the journey that you go on
once you've decided to you know go down
the bathroom like you know kubernetes
right so it's a significant amount of
research and um yeah it takes it takes a
significant amount of investment from
you know a people time perspective to
figure out you know what your you know
end State technical stack looks like
okay but let's say I do that right so I
put in that nine months then then am I
ready then can I just turn my
application developers lose where my
operations people were set
yeah that was that was going to be my
next question or my lead-in was going to
be great we've figured out now hopefully
you're along for the journey right you
know the story that we're trying to
paint here so we figured out the
technical stack
uh we made our choices uh we've decided
that the business needs a platform with
all of these capabilities we picked all
of these different you know Technologies
to underpin those specific capabilities
does it end there that's just your
that's just your day one uh what happens
after right is the question right
um significant operational challenges
ahead right and what do we mean by that
right
installation uh great you've got one
stack ready to go uh what if you get
massive success and you know everybody
wants in on the platform and you decide
to roll out this technical stack uh to
multiple you know geographies for
example right you know we deal you know
largely distributed world nowadays and
um you know you really want to provide
the same experience or a consistent
experience across your organization
across multiple GEOS so there is still a
challenge associated with have you
figured out the automation or like just
gen generally the installation aspect of
how you're going to manage this
technical stack
right and I think it's important to note
that that you've got not just one thing
you know as you just said we've got
kubernetes and many of those things run
on top of kubernetes some of those
things are running underneath kubernetes
right you're now in each of those
projects has its own release cycle so
this this process itself is is going to
be significant right as you said it's
gonna be significant every time you turn
something up every time you turn up a
new for you know yeah new data center
new region even a new cluster but now
you've got all these different
components with dependencies between
them possibly Reliance on each other and
they each have their own life cycle
right upgrade Etc
yeah exactly and upgrades that's that's
another key part of it right so if day
one signifies you know just getting a
technical stack up and running based on
the design that you put together uh what
does you know subsequent days look like
or what does post they want look like
um let's say you know quarter down the
road you decide um I really need a
specific capability that one of these
projects is getting me what is your
upgrade strategy going to look like and
then it's not just for a single cluster
because you're so successful and you
sound massive or you've seen massive
adoption uh with your platform that
you've just built uh you need to like
figure out how you're going to roll out
or what your upgrade strategy is going
to look like you know globally for all
of the Clusters that you have running in
production right so upgrade is a key
aspect Dan alluded to the whole
interoperability bit right uh so now
we've all we all know the benefits of
you know leveraging you know open source
uh but then just like Dan mentioned each
of these projects you know there really
isn't any synchronization when it comes
down to
you know the release Cycles or you know
whether someone's you really need to be
meticulous about you know going through
documentation and figuring out whether
you know a specific you know project or
a specific uh technical capability is
compatible with maybe the underlying
version of kubernetes that you're
running on you know breaking changes
happen right you know that's that's
something uh that we've seen often as
operators or someone who's been an ID
for a while you know that breaking
changes happen and uh just reading the
fine print and just ensuring that you're
managing all of those moving pieces from
an interoperability perspective is
another key Challenge from
um an operational perspective
um and last but not least security right
we are dealing with complex you know
distributed systems kubernetes by itself
is a distributed system with multiple
moving Parts
um then we're not even we haven't even
started talking about the workloads
right so it depends on the workloads
that you deploy in the platform what is
your strategy to secure you know the
workloads as a platform itself and then
the workloads that run on the platform
so I think I think one important thing
is you said the workloads are your
business and you're gonna have to you
know you've got to figure that out but
the platform I think that's a really
important thing right we just showed
that open source landscape and and you
know you're gonna need a dozen two dozen
of those of those projects at least
right you're going to become very
acquainted with the letters cve
common vulnerability uh and exposure
right
um and and each of those will have to be
something that you are paying attention
to because when some of these cves come
out they will affect you and they will
affect the you you think you you might
think you're in control of your upgrade
and your your inter interoperability and
then all of a sudden you've got to patch
a component that you didn't know you
were going to have to patch right again
aside your from your own code your
reliant on open source projects on open
source projects so security becomes a
very important operational challenge
that you have to solve right
yep
and this is this is what leaders and you
know Architects and everyone you know
working in this ecosystem are constantly
thinking about right how do I you know
the term that's being that's being
floated nowadays is reducing the
cognitive load associated with
operations right just making it simple
it's about
um
figuring out
um how I can minimize the amount of time
that I'm spending on operations
all right so I've solved that then right
or I have a strategy or I work with
somebody to figure out
um how I reduce my Cycles on my team
Cycles spent on operations uh what's
next what's next in the journey
so so I think that the thing that we
have to bear in mind as we're as we're
doing this is we're thinking about
adopting kubernetes we're adopting uh
this new technology one thing to
understand is that you have to solve
this in a way that you've solved it in
more than one place I think there was
and I spent a lot of time working at
Google cloud and uh when we spent a lot
of time and and with the other vendors
as well trying to get people to move to
the cloud thinking eventually it's all
going to run up there right eventually
people are going to choose a cloud
they're going to move everything up
there but what we're seeing increasingly
um and and what every every attendee of
this of this call is seeing is that it's
never going to be 100 in the cloud and
in fact cios are saying uh and ctOS are
saying no no no hybrid Cloud isn't a
waypoint along the destination hybrid
cloud is where we're going to end up so
as you're choosing your kubernetes
solution unless you want to double your
work double your operations staff
increase their I love that that term
their cognitive load you are going to
have to solve it in a way that it solves
both for what you run in the cloud and
on-prem and chances are it's not just
one Cloud right
yeah chances are it's not just one Cloud
it's um you know a lot of organizations
um even if they do not start off
directly with the multi-cloud strategy
they definitely want a hybrid Cloud
strategy which is a combination of their
own uh private data centers with a
primary you know cloud provider right
and that's a significant you know that
tends to be
um you know a significant
um you know investment that uh they're
you know they're definitely exploring uh
outside outside so what are what do you
think are some of the common use cases
for you know multi-cloud management this
is this is a conversation I love having
um and maybe I'll I'll throw in a couple
of those use cases so outside of you you
mentioned that
everyone's looking at a multi-cloud
strategy or a hybrid Cloud strategy
because the data is not going to move
right so the data gravity or uh
governance requirements might dictate
you know a multicraft strategy or a
hybrid Cloud strategy what else what
else are we thinking here
well if if you're if your company is big
enough if you're if you're you know
working at a fortune 2000 company uh one
of the reasons is that one of the ways
you got to be a fortune 2000 companies
was through Acquisitions you're
acquiring companies and they're already
deployed somewhere and they might be
deployed somewhere in such a way that it
is very difficult or expensive for them
to move they might be dependent on
Services they're they're absolutely
there other companies refuse to be
dependent on single vendors absolutely
in financial services I would hear about
the four Cloud strategy and the four
Cloud strategy is the three major
players plus our own and they were all
very very clear that they for sometimes
for marketing reasons sometimes for uh
resilience reasons and just not wanting
to be dependent on a single company they
wanted to ensure that they could always
choose
um so there are a bunches and sometimes
you're running a workload that someone
really does have a proprietary
technology technology running in their
cloud and it makes sense for you to run
a workload near that near that
technology yeah a couple of other common
use cases that I've come across is just
as it could be as simple as just
business continuity or Dr right we've
definitely seen a disaster recovery
right so it's just all about uh
leveraging multiple Cloud providers just
to ensure that your business is not
impacted in the event of an outage right
so that's that's one common strategy the
other one is with the rise of uh just
being
uh just having a distributed world that
we live in today is just all about you
know what I call the pop architecture
right which is a point of presence right
it's just about having uh you know your
services running as close to your user
as possible right or your end users as
possible so the idea of just having that
point of presence you know in a global
World in a world that's you know
increasingly getting digitized you know
that makes a lot of sense right so you
definitely want to have you know
multiple crowd providers in a certain
Cloud providers might not have the
regions uh that you know in a market
that you're potentially looking to tap
into so that's that's another
um integrate um you know use case as
well so the headline are we both are we
gonna both transition here you go ahead
you transition yeah yeah
all right so uh we we discussed a little
bit about you know multi-cloud and we
talked about why multi-cloud is a
challenge a little bit we touched on
that the reason we are kind of like
transitioning to this slide is we want
to talk about what some of what it
really looks like at the deployment
level right when you decided that okay
multi-cloud or hybrid cloud is something
that you really want to do what are some
of the challenges associated with
actually getting that working right so
that's kubernetes is open source right
doesn't didn't we already choose open
when we chose kubernetes I don't
understand
yeah uh we did we did you know that's
that's the aspect right you know uh
that's the aspect that we want to like
you know really talk about here
kubernetes is supposed to be open source
um so you know are we connecting the
dots yes we are right so you know we
really want to be able to use a
kubernetes-based solution in order to
like you know help um chat help with
some of those challenges that really you
know are tied to let's say a multi-cloud
strategy right so the first pillar being
here let's talk about portability uh
especially when you decide to go hybrid
Cloud uh the idea here I'm we're trying
trying to tie a couple of Concepts here
where if the objective is to have a
hybrid Cloud strategy and then as a CIO
I want to reduce the time spent on
operations
um I really don't want to have multiple
you know modes of operation when it
comes down to maintaining uh you know my
platform in a private data center or in
one of the cloud providers and you know
have a different experience all over the
place right the idea about you know
leveraging kubernetes to do this is the
fact that you have the portability of
just having a unified experience across
any infrastructure that you might be
leveraging in order to build out this
multi-cloud strategy or hybrid Cloud
strategy that you're looking for
does that help them did I I I think I
think it does and and I think there's
there's there's more too because I think
that kubernetes is absolutely open
source and and there are lots of vendors
who will Who will package a kubernetes
into a into a uh essentially a platform
for you but they don't all uh really
allow plugability at every layer right
there are some that say oh you you can
use kubernetes but you have to use it on
our operating system for example or
we've got we've got a a monitoring
system built in and we don't allow you
to plug that in and one of the beauties
of kubernetes and one of the reasons
that kubernetes won is that not just
that it was open source but that it had
plugability everywhere right if you want
look at service mesh I used to work on
the istio project right there's probably
four service meshes in in uh in the uh
Cloud native landscape so when you're
choosing kubernetes done right when
you're building not just kubernetes but
that platform and you're and you're
choosing a platform to build on you want
to ensure that your platform allows you
to plug in what you want to plug in
right and I think that that's really
important because you are cutting
yourself off from some of the Innovation
In This Cloud native landscape if you're
building a platform that when something
Innovative happens you can't plug it in
your vendor says oh no no we don't we
don't allow you to do that so I think
that's that's really important yeah
exactly right it's it's not it's not so
that's the key difference here right
it's it's not a pass right a pass is a
very opinionated way of doing things the
philosophy of the ethos behind building
a platform leveraging kubernetes is the
whole plugability aspect right you know
we have conversations
um you know all the time with folks who
have like certain opinions on you know
how a capability is delivered like let
me give you an example when we're
talking about logging for example right
so there are a bunch of uh Solutions out
there or there might be an Enterprise
standard that says this is how you have
to do logging right you know and
therefore very good reasons you know it
could be for audit purposes or you know
it could be for just ensuring that uh
you're able to you know figure out
um you know forensic information based
on access to your applications or data
so there are very good reasons why
Enterprise standards exist for a
specific you know capability and you
really want to like be able to you know
have a platform that can readily plug
into those standards or plug into uh
those specific requirements or meet
those requirements right and you know
we're you know that's that's a pretty
exciting thing about um you know
kubernetes and building out a platform
that is based on kubernetes you just
have the plugability aspect and Dan
touched on this a little bit you know
the Innovative aspect or The Innovation
aspect right there's always something uh
Innovative going on as far as you know
the community's ecosystem is concerned
you know Everyone likes talking about
the service mesh and Dan touched on that
a little bit but it's very exciting you
know for developers you know because a
service mesh allows you to you know not
really impose the limitations on your
developers right so it's a polyglit way
uh world where you know developers have
their uh preference for you know what
they're developing in and you really
want to like decouple some of the
non-functional capabilities from your
application code right so if you're
looking at you know building a
capability that's you know a dandruff or
to Mutual TLS you know just ensuring
that the applications communicate in a
secure way or you really want to like
Implement a circuit breaker patent just
to ensure
that you're able to like you know meet
certain slos or you know cut off traffic
when you know there's an incident you
know those are capabilities that a
service mesh brings to a table and
that's just one example of like some of
the Innovation that's going on in the
ecosystem right okay so I'm gonna
Devil's Advocate again uh all the cloud
providers now have managed kubernetes
again if I'm that CIO CTO
can I just
take that manage kubernetes and and
assume that that's okay right it's it's
all managed for me doesn't that solve
this problem
foreign not really
and we'll we'll talk about why right
so the question here is you know all the
cloud providers or is managed kubernetes
a solution right everyone's um you know
got a you know managed kubernetes
solution Now it only solves part of the
problem right so you know going back a
few years typically if when you were
getting started In This Cloud native
Journey that hopefully we've been uh
doing uh you know a current job of just
kind of taking you on
you start off with like figuring out
what makes sense to me from a technology
perspective you land on communities you
understand that this is the future this
is how I want to develop my applications
I want to really uh get away from the
business of managing servers I want to
abstract my underlying infrastructure
and provide my developers a great
experience all right fantastic uh but
then you know there was a period of
struggle where you know customers
typically or you know folks working with
kubernetes they go through a bunch of
challenges when it comes down to like
you know figuring out how to run this in
production right that enter the cloud
managed you know kubernetes Services
right they really abstract away some of
the really hard parts of operating
kubernetes in production right like for
example the common you know punchline or
the tagline Dan like a few years ago was
um oh man I'm just so worried because I
have to operate hcd in production right
or you know I'm troubleshooting
um you know problems with the you know
raft protocol or just trying to like you
know figure out you know what's going on
here you know why did I you know lose my
cluster right so that's a challenge the
managed Community Services definitely
solve for right they make that aspect of
operating kubernetes or that component
of communities which is settled on the
system almost a black box right so the
idea is you focus on figuring out what
your business outcomes are figuring out
the other aspects of the design that you
need that you need to be spending your
time on as per as far as the platform is
concerned right you know choosing the
appropriate um you know instances of
which machine types that you need in
order to like you know support your
workloads and figuring out the other
things that we just spent the last few
minutes talking about which was you know
building out rest of the stack Dan was
right so yeah yeah I think I think I
think that's exactly right your managed
kubernetes are fantastic offerings I
think the best advertisement they ever
got was kubernetes the hard way by
Kelsey Hightower right because it showed
installing running kubernetes is tough
you can get kubernetes out of the box
from any of the cloud vendors and never
have to worry about any of that aspect
again but those limitations that we
talked about kubernetes at its heart
really is container orchestration you
still need to layer in all those pieces
and and while different Cloud vendors
have done different things to make that
a little bit easier easier for the most
part it is not a platform out of a box
and you still need to put a lot of
pieces in place on top of it to take
that managed kubernetes into a you know
complete integrated automated platform
and now is when you get to talk about
uh why d2iq and and something like AWS
eks are better together yeah so uh we're
gonna uh you know use our you know
friends and our partners um at AWS as an
example here and eks is you know a great
distribution as far as uh great um you
know Cloud managed you know communities
um you know service that you know you
can run in production but then just like
Dan mentioned at the end of the day it's
still kubernetes and you still need to
spend a significant amount of time
trying to like figure out how you're
going to build out this feature complete
platform right so there there are a
couple of um you know patterns that
we've seen you know how customers or you
know folks working in this domain uh try
to like solve for this problem right one
is a pure do-it-yourself approach so
great uh it's a scenario that I
described right I really want to like
make the uh operations related to
kubernetes uh simple so I'm gonna go
with eks but then then I decide to
curate the rest of my you know technical
stack using open source components
perhaps you know borrowed from the cncf
landscape right so then we are back to
the same problem right what are we doing
for uh figuring out a strategy that's
going to allow you to consistently
install these on multiple clusters then
it becomes challenges related to you
know upgrades uh it goes back to uh
interoperability challenges it goes back
to security challenges right so it's
that Circle that we had like earlier in
the presentation so that's the first
approach you're you know using eks plus
uh just completely doing it yourself as
far as you know the uh rest of the
capabilities are concerned the second
approach that we've seen is obviously
the crowd vendors have managed services
that unlock you know some of these
capabilities right so for example you
know staying within the AWS ecosystem uh
you might have you know cloudwatch for
your you know logging and metrics uh
there is
um you know a solution available for
maybe you know continuous deployment on
kubernetes you could decide to like you
know Stitch all of those together and
integrate all of them with eks to get
that feature complete platform that you
need right but then obviously
uh you're gonna be uh you know if um
your CFO is watching uh you really need
to be on point in terms of just
understanding what costs all of these
represent and just be able to like you
know build out the appropriate
um you know
um you know cost model just to ensure
that um you know it meets your you know
business requirements or if you have
specific uh TCO or Roi targets you know
you really need to be uh in a cognizant
of the fact that each of these Services
costs their own
um you know money right and then and you
need to be aware of costs I mean you
need to be aware of portability right
because if you're if you're dependent on
a cloud service
um and you need to run your you know
you're in that hybrid Cloud world or
that multi-cloud world that means now
you're using different Services right
and and one thing we haven't talked
about very much is that there are many
use cases uh including on-prem in the
cloud and on-premise especially where
where you need to run an air cluster and
you can't use a cloud-based solution for
any of these in those cases so so I
think yeah the point here is is a great
one that that uh the managed kubernetes
services are fantastic
um and when you're in the cloud they're
a really good way to get kubernetes be
aware that everything else that you need
to do in terms of security in terms of
networking in terms of backup in terms
of by the way incomplete list here
um is still something that needs to be
done on top of those and you need to
solve those problems uh and you want to
solve those consistently organization
wide so you don't have individual teams
solving them in individual ways
especially differently in individual
clouds and and on-prem locations exactly
a unified operational experience right
we touched upon that a little bit you
know earlier in the presentation right
we really want to have a consistent
experience especially if you're you know
trying to tackle a hybrid Cloud
deployment or a multi-cloud you know
strategy uh you really want to strive
for have having a unified experience
irrespective of what your you know
underlying infrastructure looks like
right whether it's on-prem with bare
metal dan mentioned you know air gap
right
um if you have workloads that are
running in your private data center
um are you gonna something to think
about is are you going to have a
different operating model when it comes
down to like um you know versus what you
have in the cloud and then the third
approach that I was going to touch on a
little bit is the fact that um the cloud
vendor is obviously being very customer
first you know they are working towards
like enabling some of these capabilities
you know with eks right so we definitely
want to acknowledge that and you know
that is something that's
um you know getting Gathering ahead of
steam uh again it more or less aligns
with you know what the challenges are as
far as you know the second scenario was
concerned second scenario is concerned
which is uh you end up using you lose a
little bit of portability there just
purely because uh you're using
opinionated tooling uh which will you
you know just work in a specific Cloud
readers ecosystem and
um you know it's really not something
that you could just kind of pick up and
use when you decide to like either move
your workloads back on Prem or you
decide to
um you know leverage a different cloud
provider for whatever reason right so
the loss of portability is um you know
pretty key there as well so the graphic
on the right what it's just a man to
articulate is with dito IQs in a
kubernetes platform with eks
it's a complete integrated inaternity
solution using open source technology
that allows you to like you know
standardize your experience across any
infrastructure that's the key takeaway
here
all right all right should we uh should
we kind of wrap up the technology
portion yeah
yeah so sum it up for me how do you do
kubernetes right yeah let's yeah let's
let's put it all together let's uh let's
put it all together right so this is
this is the um this is a key takeaway
here right uh committing to open source
we really again we harp on the open
source aspect of um you know the
benefits of Open Source and why you know
portability matters uh we really want to
get to a point where there is a
standardization of operations right and
you really want to start looking at
clusters themselves as cattle right you
know the concept the initial concept of
like Cloud native uh back in the day
people talked about you know cattle
versus pets right and now it's gone to a
point where you can significantly
automate your operations where you can
start to looking at your kubernetes
clusters themselves as cattle right so
how do you do that is through the use of
you know get ups and decorative apis uh
just like you would you know Deploy
workloads on kubernetes using
deployments uh adopt a mindset that just
allows you to declare the state of a
communities cluster and get up and
running you know really quick without
any human intervention you really don't
want to be running scripts all over the
place and you know uh using something
that's really custom and um you know run
into like operational challenges every
time you decide to
um you know either stand up in your
deployment or upgrade you know existing
you know kubernetes uh I can't emphasize
that enough I I was I know a company
that was looking at opening a new region
and they were budgeting a quarter to
open up their new region and and the
reason is that that bottom it's it's all
run by humans yes yes there's scripted
stuff they've automated some things but
they are literally yeah it's going to
take months to ensure everything is
installed in that region the Clusters
are created properly they were running
some kubernetes and some VMS but that's
not the way you want to be when it's
time to turn up another cluster
somewhere that should be as simple as a
change in a config file and everything
else happens everything every bit in
that stack from the deployment of
kubernetes whether it's a managed
kubernetes or not to every everything
else that happens should be declarative
and opening up that that new region or
you know falling over to it it might
just be a new it might just be a new
availability zone right it doesn't have
to be you're opening a new region should
be uh should be uh done in that way yeah
exactly and the power and then yeah yeah
and make sure that you're ready for your
deployment patterns right you might have
some things that need to run in a
particular place you might have some
things that need to run on-prem
understand those those going in so as
you're choosing your solutions they will
work there if you have a reason to run
air gap clusters weather on-prem or or
in the cloud or in a moving vehicle for
example make sure that you're choosing a
solution that's going to work in those
those different deployment patterns
words
yeah exactly work your way backwards
from you know what your business needs
right you know that's that's uh I that's
that's kind of like my line you know
just working uh don't do not make um you
know decisions that are really not going
to serve your organizations you know
purpose right so figure out like if it's
an on-prem strategy that you need or if
they're for specific reasons you need to
have an air gap deployment or uh you're
deploying a platform to the edge you
know we've seen some pretty cool you
know use cases where you want to move
the compute you know towards the edge
you know where the data is right and you
can definitely uh enable or you can use
kubernetes to build a platform that
enables that deployment pattern right so
I think we find that like pretty
exciting it definitely lends itself to
uh enabling really cool use cases you
know going going forward right
um you know I made this comment earlier
the world is you know increasingly uh
app Centric and getting digitized and
you know people want to build
applications that um
um you know unlock new streams of
Revenue or whether it's uh just engaging
uh new customers or like you know
figuring out
um ways to you know optimize on how
experiences for your end users might
look like right and all these lend
themselves to like different deployment
patterns and we think you know a
kubernetes-based platform uh obviously
Done Right is uh you know a way of
definitely uh tackling those uh you know
business challenges right and then okay
being hold on being cognizant of time I
think we should say okay so so this is
how you do it right from a technology
perspective yeah but I know that there's
one last point you want to hit and that
is uh is it just technology
it's not just technology right so uh
this is you know for folks who have
worked with me in the past it's like
they always say uh for me a success is a
function of you know people process and
Technology right so while we spend uh
the Lion's Share of this presentation
you know just talking about you know the
technology challenges or how we we solve
for some of these technical problems
um you know be cognizant of the fact
that we really need to involve um people
and uh build the appropriate processes
in order to be successful as well so you
know this graphic again just talks about
you know some of the common you know
user challenges that um you know
organizations grapple with in order to
like you know get this right
um so some of this includes you know
just making some of these cultural
changes right in order to have a devops
mindset or start building up you know
practice around you know git Ops you
need to have transparency and
collaboration right so a highly siled
organizations you know where think of it
as you know the development teams not
talking to the operational teams or vice
versa you know that really doesn't you
know really lend itself or like putting
in a position where uh you're going to
be successful with this initiative that
you're taking on right so I I think that
that's the most interesting thing here
is that when you ask users what their
challenges is number one is culture yeah
right number one isn't isn't a
technology and this is what you ask the
people the the issues and if we go look
at the organizational challenges on the
next slide I think you see something
else very interesting which is when you
ask organizations what's the biggest
problem for you adapting adopting
kubernetes look over there monitoring
health and performance of kubernetes
clusters seems like that'd be important
it's relatively small more important is
the thing we all hear about is how do I
refactor my monolith to to actually
running kubernetes but even that more
important than that is the thing that
Shafiq we've talked a lot about today
which is how do you manage kubernetes
itself and that ecosystem of all the
components but the most important thing
is the people right the number one
challenge people are having and what I
find that's interesting in this
two-thirds of people say their biggest
problem with Cloud native is finding
attracting and retaining qualified
kubernetes talent my opinion shavik is
they're they're looking at this the
wrong way that you can't look at how do
we hire all new people who understand
kubernetes I think that the lesson that
I'm hoping that cios ctOS are CEOs who
are learning here is that we've got to
bring our people along we've got to give
our people the practices the tools the
training what they need to adopt to this
new world because if if you're going to
be trying to replace all of your
developers all of your operators
you're going to fall farther behind
yeah exactly uh invest in your people
there's uh great training available from
an operator in a Persona perspective
um there's great training that you know
allows developers to you know adopt a
cloud native mindset and leverage you
know kubernetes effectively right so
that's definitely you know part of the
solution right
which will say giving you perfectly into
hey look at that yeah that's that's what
it is it's it's all about you know
people process and Technology right it's
about organizing for Success you know um
you know the making the cultural changes
are probably the hardest right but
that's something that you definitely
have to take a uh look at you know if
you really want to become you know a
devops or git Ops you know process uh
based organization you know uh changing
your organization to reflect that is
something that needs to happen right
training and enablement is key
um if you don't have you know the Cycles
or you know you are struggling to like
you know really get your enablement
programs or your cultural change
programs off the ground engage with an
expert or you know just figure out if
there's a vendor out there that can you
know help you with your journey right
and you know they can come to the table
give you the best practices known
practices and um you know that way
accelerate your journey from to Cloud
native maturity right
yep
all right that's it so this is going to
be the real uh final slide here right
which is
um just tying all of this together so
what do we mean by doing kubernetes
right
um you know adopt a complete platform
right so kubernetes is just kubernetes
if you're looking to build a feature
complete platform uh there's a lot more
that you need to think about uh keep it
open you know leverage uh open source it
gives you the benefits of uh all the
Innovation that's going on in the
ecosystem gives you the portability
associated with like using open source
technology but there is a significant
amount of
um you know innovation in the automation
space as well which is allows you to
like really treat uh the platforms or
your clusters as cattle right you know
declare everything
um allow you know the automation to do
its work right and hybrid and
multi-cloud is the destination you know
a lot of um you know Common deployment
patterns nowadays are hybrid and
multi-cloud in nature
um again it all comes down to what your
business needs and uh it's just not
about the technology so think people
process and Technology